Albert Breer senior NFL reporter for the
Monday Morning Quarterback also works
NBC sports Boston who joins us on the
program Albert what's the state of the
draft right now Dan I think almost every
team is expecting they're gonna have to
do it from home you know there was a
memo that went out last week that
basically said that there's going to be
one of two things that are going to
happen either everybody's going to be
able to use their team facility or no
one's going to be able to congregate at
all and everybody's gonna have to do the
draft from home and I don't know if
you've seen these maps but you know I
the latest map I saw showed that 31 of
the 32 teams are under stay at home
orders now and so it's really hard to
envision a scenario where all 32 teams
are going to be allowed by the rules in
their state to go into their facilities
so they're gonna almost certainly be
running the draft from home and there
are a lot of pitfalls that the league
and the teams are working through I mean
it comes it goes all the way down to the
internet connection in your house which
I like teams and running their meetings
now which be all that stuff's happening
from home now teams are having problems
with that so there's a lot of work to do
in the next two and a half weeks I've
been mentioning this morning the last
hour and a half periodically that a
source said there's some internal
pressure that depending what happens
over the next seven to ten days in our
country that you know it might be wise
to postpone this until the middle of May
like what's the harm in doing something
like that have you heard anything where
they would postpone it a couple of weeks
which you know might allow teams to have
a war room where they can go into we
don't know where the Commissioner is
gonna be is the Commissioner gonna
handle the draft from his house I mean
that's
yeah and that's what's been floated out
there I know like the two kind of ideas
that they'd been working with one well
as the Commissioner was going to run the
draft from his house and then the other
was that they were going to run the
draft out of Bristol I'm out of ESPN's
headquarters and have simulcast there
and so it could be one it could be the
other it could be both but there's
definitely a boat this way there are a
lot of general managers and a lot of
head coaches that feel right now like
everybody's going to putting a
tough spot if the draft goes off on time
and that's without even getting to their
own feelings on how tone-deaf it might
seem to be doing this is this situation
worsens in our country and so you know I
know a lot of the general managers who
are on this subcommittee have pushed
back on the idea of going with the draft
on time you know and and and I think
that the big pushback on that was well
what difference does it make it won't it
won't be any different in May or June
and now you can sort of see that swing
back around where you know some people
are saying well what's the rush then
because yeah teams aren't going to be
starting up until July anyway I mean the
off season program in all likelihood is
going to be wiped out so like if you're
not if the rookies not going to be
showing up til the middle of the summer
anyway then why are we in this huge rush
to do this while the situation gets so
much worse in our country I also brought
this up and you know there's a roller
coaster you can see this every year with
the draft certainly with quarterbacks
you know Jordan love got all that
attention and then all of a sudden we
start to tear him down
Justin Herbert got all that attention
then we started to nitpick a little bit
now it's to uh on the clock and it feels
like now people start to slice and dice
to a tongue of I Aloha because and we're
not talking about the injuries but I saw
this on bleacher report with Matt Miller
and he was talking about you know Scouts
were looking at some of the problems
with tua it happens every year doesn't
it yeah yeah the biggest problem with
too is the medical and I don't think
it's I know I feel her focus on the hip
and that's still an issue no question
and he's not - he's not going to be
totally out of the woods on draft day
there's still some complications that
could come up with the hip after that
but really it's the multitude of
injuries the teams are worried about
those two ankle surgeries that he had in
Alabama those are new surgeries so
there's really no track record on how
those are going to hold up long term and
then you've got just the the massive
amount of injuries and you know look
like if you want to go back and look at
history Dan and people look at these
injuries and say well you know it's bad
luck the kid could overcome it
history shows and so over the last
decade the quarterback to go in the
first round and come into the
come into the draft with serious medical
history from college almost all get hurt
again
Sam Bradford and tan Jake Locker and 11
Robert Griffin in 12 Marcus Mariota and
15 Carson Wentz and 16 - Shaun Watson
and 17 Josh Rosen turn 18 all of them
had significant injury history in
college all of them got hurt again in
the pros and so teams look at that and
say we like to as a player but can we
trust and he's going to be able to stay
healthy and I got to tell you look at
that list in to us got more history than
most of those guys - so I still think
the medicals apart of it he's not a
perfect prospect but I can tell you this
the Bama coaches have told NFL people we
believe he's a left-handed drew Brees
I've got enough NFL people agree with
that assessment to make me think that
he's very well thought of as a player
really the major promise of medical what
are the Dolphins going to do what should
and what will the Dolphins do well I
think they'd love to get you over oh but
I don't think it's going to happen the
Bengals have done a lot of relationship
building I'll put it that way with your
borough you know they've got a guy in
their team name Sam Hubbard who is
actually a college roommates of jail
roommate of Joe burrows Zach Taylor
actually had a little bit of a
relationship with Joe burrows dad for
them having recruited the same area a
few years ago when Zach Taylor was the
University of Cincinnati and so I just I
don't think the Bengals are going to
move off their spot on this one so that
leaves the dolphin sitting there five
and they did a ton of homework on tua I
mean look the owner the team president
the GM they were all at - his bowl game
and - it didn't even play so that's the
amount of research and homework they're
do what they've done into - uh but that
can also swing the other way where maybe
now they know enough about the medical
to feel uncomfortable with it and so I
still think they probably take a
quarterback do they move to get one I'm
not sure and I'm telling you I'm if they
the choice of - I'm not so sure it would
be - over Justin Herbert right now
really I'm not positive on that yeah
okay we're talking Albert Breer senior
NFL reporter for the Monday Morning
Quarterback calm you start to look at
landing spots for Cam Newton Jameis
Winston Andy Dalton
Jadeveon Clowney I mean it feels like
clowny is gonna get paid and he's going
to have opportunities here but let's
start with cam the the market is
shrinking rapidly yeah and this is like
the weirdest circumstance isn't it
because forever people who are looking
for quarterbacks and overpaying
quarterbacks overdrafting quarterbacks
now it's almost like that bubble burst
where you know the supply actually
outweighed the demand this offseason and
that left cam and Annie Dalton and
Jameis without a seat when the music
stops so I think part of cams problem is
absolutely the medical in the
circumstance that all teams and players
are in right now where you can't give
guys physicals and teams want to get a
look at his right shoulder and teams
want to get look a look at his left foot
and they can't do that right now and so
that part of its a big piece of all of
this and then the other piece of it is
I mean look cam has been the centerpiece
of every team he's been on for the last
ten years
how would he fit in if he was a little
less than that if he was not that you
know and so that's a question that I
think teams have to sort through with
him too so you know I my personal
feeling is right now he might be and it
sounds crazy but he may be forced to go
somewhere on a one-year deal to try and
rehabilitate his stomach a little bit
and you know the Chargers seem happy
with Tyrod but if they strike out on
getting a quarterback in the draft maybe
they revisit it
New England if his price came way down
there they've got cab issues those are
the two I just it's hard to find him a
home right now because there's no place
that can bring him in and say to him Kim
you're our starting quarterback from day
one
what about Jameis Winston and Andy
Dalton yeah so Jameis to me is the one
that like I look at him and it would
make sense for him to go kind of the
teddy bridgewater out where Teddy you
know it's and obviously the
circumstances were a little different
but Teddy was coming off the injury and
sort of had to re-establish himself as a
player and went to a really stable
organization with good coaching and
benefited from having been in New
Orleans for two years
so could Jameis do that and say a place
like a Pittsburgh or a Seattle or you
know even even in New Orleans you know
like could he go to a place that's got
an established starter good coaching
where he can
rehabilitate himself you know just from
a perception standpoint for a year
I think that's probably will wind up
happening with him and I had any Dalton
tag for the Jaguars
just because Jay Gruden's there and
they've got a close relationship and I
thought at some point like that would
make some sense as like a Gardner
Minshew insurance policy but I was told
over the last couple of days that the
Jags haven't shown a ton of interest in
that yet now maybe they will post draft
but but the Jaguars haven't shown a ton
of interest in that yet but I think
Dalton will have to find that sort of
situation we're sort of like Ryan
Tannehill last year maybe you go to a
place where the starters on shaky ground
you go and you're the good soldier
backup and then if something goes wrong
you step in
Patriots cutting Khosla Cody Kessler
means what it means i I think it means
they probably draft one and I don't
think it's necessarily gonna be that
high but I think they're of a mindset
right now to start throwing darts at
that dart board they really like jared
Stidham and if you break down the
trajectory of Jared Stidham it actually
makes some sense that he could be seen
as a franchise type guy who's the number
one high school quarterback in the
country coming out had tough
circumstances at Baylor played in an
offense that didn't fit him in Auburn
the Patriots viewed him as a distressed
asset a very talented distressed asset
for those reasons when they drafted him
last year and he had a good summer last
year so they like him but they're not
going all-in on him yet so I think sort
of like you remember really how Seattle
when Pete Carroll and John Schneider got
there they just started throwing darts
at the dartboard and it was Charlie
Whitehurst and it was matt flynn it was
to virus jackson eventually they landed
russell wilson i think that sort of
where the Patriots go right now where
they like Stidham
they give them a shot but they just kind
of keep throwing darts at the dartboard
good to talk to you Albert thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time as
always
good stuff Albert brear senior NFL
reporter for the Monday Morning
Quarterback calm